(beeping)
(uptempo electronic music)
- So, what I'd like to
tell you about today
is our efforts to get a high temporal
and spatial resolution of
changes in membranes in the cell,
and what we're doing is
using electron microscopy
with a technique that's
called flash and freeze.
And the key to this technique
is to be able to synchronize the cell
at a particular time
and then look at events
that occur afterward.
And so, we've come up with two methods
for synchronizing cellular activity.
The first is light stimulation
and the second is electrical stimulation,
so I'll tell you about both of those.
So, the way a synapse works is shown here,
I think a lot of you
are familiar with that.
This is the vision of Barnard Katz
and here's the cell body of the neuron
and an action potential
travels down this axon
and then invades the bouton,
the presynaptic bouton.
And what that does is open
voltage-gated calcium channels
and calcium channels then open up
and cause the fusion of synaptic vesicles
filled with neurotransmitter
to fuse with the plasma membrane
and release those
molecules onto ligand-gated
ion channels on the postsynaptic surface.
And so, at the time this was not believed.
It was thought that
these synaptic vesicles
that were observed did in
fact contain neurotransmitter
but they were lower,
just storage organelles
for neurotransmitter.
And the reason was that no
one had seen these vesicles
actually fused with the plasma
membrane after a stimulus.
And so, it wasn't clear
that this part of the
hypothesis was correct.
And it took some 23 years
before that was proven
and that was proven by the work of
John Heuser and Tom Reese
because they built a
really cool instrument
called the freeze slammer
and that's what's shown here.
So they have a piece of
the frog pectoral muscle
which is really thin and
can freeze very rapidly.
And then they have nerves
that are still attached
and wrapped around stimulating wires
and these stimulating wires,
this whole apparatus was
attached here to this rod
and the stimulating wires went up
and could be connected to a circuit.
And so, what they could do
then was release this solenoid
and then as the bar was
following through space
they would calculate five milliseconds
before it hit a copper block,
cooled the four Kelvin,
stimulate the motor neurons
which would then cause an action potential
which would then cause the
release of neurotransmitter
at the neuromuscular junction.
And then they could ask whether
the vesicles actually fused
and this is the image
they got out of that,
absolutely spectacular.
So here is a frog neuromuscular junction
which has not been stimulated.
You can see that there are vesicles
that are docked at that surface.
And stimulated and then frozen,
five milliseconds later you
see these beautiful fusions
that are taking place that
of the synaptic vesicles
fusing with the plasma membrane
and releasing neurotransmitter.
So, Katz's quantal and vesicle hypothesis
was thereby proved.
But Tom and John also recognized
that there was another problem
and that is that there
was a limited number
of synaptic vesicles at a synapse.
And so at a neuromuscular
junction maybe there's 300
and a mouse neuromuscular
junction can fire
at a hundred times a second.
So, at these rates you can
see that the synaptic vesicles
could be rapidly consumed
and then you would exhaust the synapse
and would no longer be functional.
And so they then were convinced
that these synaptic vesicles
had to be recycled locally.
It would take a week for
vesicles to be transported
down the axon to replenish a synapse.
So there had to be local recycling.
And so, what they did was they used their
freeze slammer once again
and now instead of freezing
five milliseconds after stimulation
would freeze one second
and then two seconds
and 10 seconds, 15 seconds to 30 seconds,
and then look at each of those stages
and see whether they can see
membrane being taken back in.
Now this is a freeze fracture,
so what they've done is
they've taken their ice block
and they've with a wedge on the side,
and that ice block will break
where the weak parts are.
So where are the weak parts?
It's where the lipid bilayers are.
So there's no covalent bonds
between those lipid bilayers,
everything else is
frozen and stuck together
so when they strike the block
it splits at the lipid bilayer,
they can coat that with an
electron dense material,
take those replicas and put
them in the electron microscope.
And this is what they saw.
At zero milliseconds, that
is an unstimulated synapse,
you could see these little buttons
and those are likely
to be calcium channels.
At five milliseconds after stimulation
they could see these indentations
and these are vesicles
that are on the other
side of the screen, right?
We're looking at the face of the synapse.
Those are now fusing with the membrane
and creating these dimples.
Then they looked at one second
and, you know, for three
seconds, 10 seconds and so on,
and they saw nothing.
And it wasn't until 30
seconds that they began to see
these proteins would come
together and form clusters
and then they would be pulled inside,
So you see these little dips,
this one in particular is beautiful
because you can see the
neck where it broke off
because of course you can't
break into that concave surface.
When they looked at cross-sections
they saw that these invaginations
were coated with this
electron dense material
and it had been seen before.
This is clathrin.
And so, they now were able to say that
at synapses after stimulation
that vesicles or membranes from
that are lost to the plasma
membrane are recycled
via this clathrin-mediated process
and the process is rather slow,
it takes about 30 seconds.
So, we have revisited those experiments
and I think we see another
process that's occurring.
We call this ultra-fast endocytosis
and in this case we see
that the membrane is
removed from the surface
between 50 to 300 milliseconds
in a mouse neuron.
This then generates a synaptic
endosome within one second,
these are budded by clathrin
into mature synaptic vesicles
that can be refilled and
reused in five seconds.
So the process that we're
observing is much faster
than what had been observed
by Heuser and Reese.
When we started these experiments
we needed the way to
replicate the freeze slammer,
we needed to freeze the
samples as quickly as possible
and it needed to be deep
because the first organism
that we did this in was C. elegans
and so, it's 80 to 100 microns thick,
so we needed to have a frozen
sample all the way through.
The way that a high-pressure freezer works
it goes from 1,000 to 2,000
atmospheres in 15 milliseconds.
So the water molecules
are vibrating around
but under high pressure
they become sluggish.
And if you can drop the
temperature fast enough
then you don't have
time for those molecules
to reorder themselves and
then generate ice crystals.
Ice crystals will shred your cells
so there will be no morphology left.
And so, by doing this we're
able to freeze the sample
without any distortions from ice crystals.
So we're doing this like,
the experiments I'm gonna show you here
are not done in C.
Elegans, in the nematode.
They're done in cultured
hippocampal neurons.
And so, now what we need to do
is we have these in the
high pressure chamber
but we need some way to
initiate a depolarization
that will then initiate
that action potential,
and then stimulate this synapse
so that we can look for vesicle fusions
and endocytosis at that synapse.
And the way we're doing that
is with channelrhodopsin.
So, channelrhodopsin is a
light-activated ion channel.
When you stimulate it
with 470 nanometer light
you can then open that channel
and sodium will flow into that neuron,
and then cause an action potential.
So we now have a way to
stimulate an action potential
in a neuron that's deep inside
this high-pressure chamber.
So, let me just show you
that this actually works.
Here is a neuron that's
expressing channelrhodopsin.
This is an on cell configuration.
We stimulate with light and
here is the light stimulus,
it's 10 milliseconds long
and you can see these
beautiful action potentials
that are occurring during
the light stimulus.
Usually there's just one
but in this case we see that there are two
action potentials occurring.
We can then move that pipette
to a postsynaptic neuron
that is not expressing channelrhodopsin
so it will not be stimulated by light
but it will receive
inputs from this neuron.
So we flashed the light that
now fires an action potential
and what we can see are
these postsynaptic currents.
These are synaptic
currents, they're beautiful
and you can see in this case
we also had two action potentials
that were leading to this
postsynaptic current.
So then we now have a neuron
that's expressing channelrhodopsin
in our high pressure chamber
but we need to get a light
path into that chamber.
And so, we modified the like
high-pressure freezer at the time.
And so, it is composed
of this structure here.
So here's the specimen cup,
that's where our neurons are going to go
and it's held in place by a bayonet.
And this bayonet will
then fire down a rail
into the high-pressure chamber,
the chamber will close and then it fires
and freezes the sample.
So what we did was we,
here's this little cup
that holds the neurons.
There's a black diamond anvil here
and the pressure comes here
and slams out against
that black diamond anvil
and creates 2,000 atmospheres.
Liquid nitrogen flows
around on either side
to freeze this sample.
So what we did was we
replaced that sapphire,
the black anvil with a sapphire anvil.
We then drilled out that mounting screw
and we drilled out the bayonet
so that we had an LED right at this point
and now we have a light
path to the sample.
So, the experiment now is quite simple.
We're going to provide a 10
millisecond light stimulus
and then we'll freeze at 15 milliseconds,
30 milliseconds, 50 milliseconds,
100 milliseconds, 300
milliseconds, et cetera.
And these were the first images we got
and we were extremely excited by these
because they're just beautiful.
So, if we freeze 15 milliseconds
after the stimulation
we see vesicles fusing
with the plasma membrane.
It's just, isn't that beautiful?
It's collapsing into the
membrane here at 30 milliseconds
almost fully collapsed into the membrane.
So we can capture those very rapid events
caused by an action potential
causing vesicles to fuse.
So, what about recycling, right?
Remember it took 30 seconds
in the Heuser and Reese experiments
and we came up, we saw
he had a huge surprise
when we saw that recycling
of the membrane was occurring
on the scale of 100 milliseconds.
Here's the active zone,
that's where vesicles are fusing.
And at the lateral edge at 50 milliseconds
you can already see this
invagination that's building.
At 100 milliseconds it's much deeper
and this one you can actually see
some electron dense material.
The membrane is being cut from the surface
so that is the act of endocytosis.
And then at 300 milliseconds you can see
that the vesicle's been completely cleaved
from the membrane.
So, we can now calculate the time
during which endocytosis is taking place
and that is seen by quantifying
the number of each of
these structures we see.
We see the first pits at 30 milliseconds
then we see large vesicles
form at 50 milliseconds.
We see the last pits
forming at 300 milliseconds.
And so, that determines the
first presence of vesicles
and the last presence of
the appearance of vesicles,
so endocytosis is taking place
between 50 to 300 milliseconds.
This is a tomogram and it's
really an important image,
so I want to spend a minute on it.
What we've done here is done a tilt series
and reconstructed the electron densities
inside that thick section.
And we have now drawn this membrane,
the presynaptic membrane
slightly transparent.
You can see the postsynaptic density
which is shown in red
through that membrane
and so that defines where
the synaptic vesicles are being released
and where the receptors
are on the other side.
In this synapse you can see that there are
three synaptic vesicles
fusing at this point
in this active zone.
Look here already you can
see these invaginations
that are taking place at the
lateral edge of the synapse.
This means that the membrane
that is in the synaptic vesicle
and is fusing is not the same membrane
that is being taken up by
ultra-fast endocytosis.
Here at 100 milliseconds
the fusions have fully
collapsed into the membrane.
Here's one of those shallow invaginations
and here's one that's being
cleaved from the surface,
the active endocytosis.
We're able to then follow
what happens to this membrane later
and what you can see is that it is
transported to the back of the synapse
and it makes these large
synaptic endosomes shown here.
And then this synaptic
endosome is then cut apart
by clathrin into individual
synaptic vesicles.
And here is a 3D view of that
and if we just focus on one of these buds,
when you just look at
densities you can see
that in fact there's a
clathrin geodesic dome
or buckyball forming around
one of these vesicles.
That was great.
We were able to see this new process
called ultra-fast endocytosis
but it came under a lot of criticism,
and I think if valid if
you're trying to make
a major claim here,
one of our reviewers said
that there are 40 years of experiments
that suggest that
clathrin-mediated endocytosis
is the mechanism by which
synaptic vesicles are recycled.
And there's probably 10,000 papers
and now there's one paper that says
it's not the way it works.
One of the major thing
people were focusing on
is that we are seeing four
synaptic vesicle equivalents
being endocytosed.
And so, why and with the dogma is that
there's only one vesicle fusing.
There are people who think
that that's not true,
that there are multi vesicular release
but nevertheless, that's
how people imagine
the synapse works.
And they all hinged on the fact that
we were using channelrhodopsin
instead of electrical stimulation
which is what everybody else uses.
And I actually have to thank my critics
because they were relentless
but they're well-meaning
because all of these criticisms
were told to my face at meetings.
And they said you got to figure this out.
And so, the ideas were that
there's a excess depolarization
by channelrhodopsin, that's possible.
There was increased membrane
fluidity by channelrhodopsin
but also possible.
And that there was calcium
influx by channelrhodopsin
as well and that was leading
to these greater responses
in this unusual form of endocytosis.
So the solution is obvious.
Come up with a way to stimulate
these samples electrically
and we call this zap and freeze.
So and I have to give credit
to my senior research fellow
who came up with this, Wayne Davis.
He said this is what your
middle plate looks like
in the center of that
high-pressure chamber.
And the sample is held right here.
And so, the light comes in
and stimulates that sample
and causes the neurons to
fire action potentials.
So he said why don't you
just move the sample holder,
the sample cup to this lateral position.
Add stimulating leads,
add capacitors that will carry a charge
and then add a light-activated switch,
so that when you now take this,
insert it into the high-pressure chamber,
the light will stimulate that switch
and then cause a depolarization
of the cells in your sample
and cause action potentials.
And so, this is what we did,
this is what this thing looks like.
It is a independent little circuit board
that fits deep into the
high pressure chamber.
You can see the capacitors here
and here is where our specimens go
and then the leads are on either side.
And so, these are the images,
the first images that
came from this device.
Here is an unstimulated sample
and then here is a stimulated sample.
This is one action potential
at 1.2 million molar calcium
so this is physiological.
And you can see that
there are three vesicles
that have fused with the membrane
and are collapsing into
the plasma membrane.
So this is frozen after a single stimulus
and frozen 11 milliseconds
after the pulse.
So what about ultra fast endocytosis?
Now what we've done is we stimulate once,
it's a one millisecond pulse
and then we freeze 100 milliseconds later.
And now again here's the active zone,
postsynaptic densities marked here
and here is an invagination.
Here is an invagination,
Here is an invagination
and here's another invagination
at the lateral edge of the active zone
once again showing that
ultra-fast endocytosis
takes place even with
electrical stimulation.
Here's the quantitation of that.
Here's an unstimulated sample
and here is a sample stimulated
100 milliseconds earlier
and we see the presence
of these endocytic pits
and endocytic vesicles.
So it looks like ultra-fast
endocytosis takes place
along with, well, we'll see when
a clathrin-mediated endocytosis occurs
but we see these very fast responses
that disagree with what
people have been seeing
in hippocampal neurons.
The issue is why do our results differ
from those who have been imaging
hippocampal neurons in the past?
And I think we know the answer now
and the answer is temperature.
So we did all of our
experiments at either 34 degrees
because that's where
electrophysiologists like to record.
Or 37 degrees which is
physiological for the mouse.
And when we do that we see these large
endocytic vesicles forming
and we see ultra-fast endocytosis.
When Shigeki did his
experiments at 22 degrees,
you now see that clathrin-mediated
endocytosis takes over.
So you can see a clathrin coat there,
here's an enlargement of
that beautiful clathrin coat.
What we think is going on is at 34 degrees
we see normal, we see
ultra-fast endocytosis
and then at 22 degrees we
see clathrin-coated pits
and clathrin-mediated endocytosis.
In conclusion, we think that normally
we have ultra-fast endocytosis
removing membrane from the
surface after action potentials.
And then in the absence
of ultra-fast endocytosis
there's an emergency backup system
which is clathrin-mediated endocytosis.
And with that I would just like to thank
the people who did the work.
All the electron microscopy
was done by Shigeki Watanabe
who has his own lab now at Johns Hopkins.
Instrumentation was from Wayne Davis.
I'd really like to thank
the people at Leica
particularly Cveta Tomova.
They provided us with every
one of their instruments
every summer at MBL and they would say
do whatever you want to it.
We just need to take a picture of it
at the end of this summer.
And so I have no financial
interest in Leica.
We turned over all
intellectual property to Leica
and so these things are
now available commercially
and you can use them.
And then finally my host in
Berlin, Christian Rosenmund
and thank you for listening.
(audience applauding)
(uptempo electronic music)